[Music]  we interrupt this broadcast for an  emergency alert the Department of  Defense is confirming reports of an  unknown object entering Earth's  atmosphere an alien artifact landed on  earth we need to know why and they want  me to lead the mission the trip is six  months if all goes as planned I am  coming back I promise you it's the most  important mission in the history of  humankind  it's time  here we go  we are on our way to a planet full of  aliens  I found something really these things do  you think are out there  our first contact an alien civilization  is a risk people will die  we are all here for the same reason to  protect the lives of the people back on  earth wait what was that  I'm gonna count  it's happened here is going to happen  earth  I saved the crew  st. earth  what if I can meet the seed launch into  an interstellar war  we don't have a choice  [Music]